you ever talk to your parents and they
talked about how they were like when
they were younger back in my day back in
my day how so how so I just like just
talking to my parents and uh you know
whenever they go out to a party with
their mates or whatever whenever they're
teenagers and uh they would just tell
their parents okay I'm going hang out
with friends bye and um just maybe like
no way to contact them yeah and just you
were just as a parent you would just
have to hope
obviously if that's if contacting them
is never an option and it's never been
an option yeah then it's something that
you're like oh no this is normal yeah
right like and I think that the moment
phones get introduced you're like oh now
I now I can now I can check because yeah
that feeling where you'd be worried you
just convinced yourself oh no this
happens all the time yeah right but now
it's like okay you can just message yeah
now they didn't reply you're like right
[__] off man you start to freak out yeah
right so I think that we're just really
good at adapting to whatever
circumstance we're in and if we don't
have a way of contacting we don't give a
[__] we'll adapt but if we do yeah then
we're like oh God oh God oh God God I
remember I remember my mom talking about
you know early in her life uh going
through some long-distance relationships
and uh having to wait months that is
weird for a physical letter oh yeah I
know I'm just like what I cannot even
like fathom that yeah that's people in
the 1800s were like first time
yeah that's strange to me yo someone
just someone just dropped in my DMs man
look at this but I guess
but it's also like you know how maybe
you you go to the Onsen right like you
get naked and that's a completely normal
concept
if but in the western world it's not a
concept anymore but maybe it was at one
point yeah it's like we're just we just
get told things that like this is normal
this is normal behavior yeah and then
we're like oh okay cool cool and we just
adapt like straight up yeah I think I
think humans are just very you know very
good at adapting to situations we're
very good at adapting even to uncomfort
and uh yeah yeah even if a situation is
bad uh we're just our brain is just I
think built to just adapt to it uh just
because sometimes it takes more effort
to try and combat it than to actually
just go along with it yeah and that's
why like sometimes when I am on YouTube
shorts and Tick Tock a lot of times if I
feel if I sometimes I can like
it's almost like I can feel my brain
chemistry changing some some sometimes
and as soon as I feel that like hook I'm
like no this is this is an uncomfortable
feeling I'm gonna stop now yeah
otherwise I'm going to be here for three
hours I think it makes me Dumber
it definitely does it definitely makes
me Dumber like I genuinely feel like I
lose intelligence every day maybe that
should have anything no I think so as
well because okay okay yeah
I'm okay with that yeah that sounds like
a you problem I don't know what you guys
have been recommended recently like I
don't know why I've been recommended
this [__] recently but I feel like every
other YouTube short or Tick Tock I've
been recommended recently is a [__]
clip from some podcast or something and
they talk about this random historic
facts and then the the evidence you know
that in the Egyptian days they didn't
have ADHD they used to just spank them
into it it's like and then they just
executed yeah that one Tick Tock music
the one over his ears
stranger things
and it's just like did you know about
this piece of events that we uncovered
in like in like the AF uh the uh Amazon
rainforest that no one talks about yeah
Lost Civilization yeah that's all I'm
saying and I know I'm just like why are
these all getting recommended to me
somewhere you know what you got me let's
see the next one I'm like you know what
you know what there is that is pretty
strange that there are pyramids all over
the world and everyone decided to build
them in the same shape oh no wait
how many possible shapes can you arrange
like stone blocks there's like you can
give like a five-year-old Lego he'd
probably be able to build the Great
Pyramids of Giza by himself you know
yeah and it's yeah I don't I don't know
there are a lot of tick-tock holes and
YouTube short holes that you can easily
fall into and I feel like sometimes it
makes you feel smarter while you're
watching it and then you stop it and
you're like I think I actually got
Dumber you're like yeah I've watched so
many Netflix documentaries we've talked
about like a million times on this
podcast and I barely retain any of that
information I don't know why yeah why do
I not retain any information from stuff
I watch I think it's because it's not
significant to your life at that moment
right or or probably for the foreseeable
future right because if it's like you
know if it's something that has to do
directly with like you know your way of
living right say if it's like oh I gotta
learn how to use this new piece of tech
or the software that actually is going
to help me in the future then you're
going to retain that information but if
it's like oh I watched this uh
documentary on you know Jeffrey Epstein
and why he was a you know horrible
[__] person right then it's like okay
well that's information that's good to
know but it's not integral to my
survival you know yeah I guess so I
don't know like I said through the whole
[__] Epstein documentary and the only
thing I [__] pertained was that he
was a piece of [__]
I saw all the details and I'm like do I
remember any of the details not really
it is weird that's weird I don't know
why we like I I when I see people who
are uh like know everything about a show
they love oh my God I wish that I wish I
had that I wish I I wish I had to retain
any information about half the [__] I
watch I don't know I feel like that
actually loses what do you mean every
like they know everything like when you
hear about people who are like obsessed
with like Star Wars and they can just
tell you every little detail about it
I'm like man yeah but that's probably
their life right like that's that's part
of the thing yeah but I wish I had that
passion to give a [__] to remember
anything I don't even I've watched so
many anime and I feel like half more
than half like two-thirds like I watched
all the chainsaw man and I forgot who
Aki was I was like amazing was like oh
yeah like Aki that character I was like
he's like the wolf guy I'm like yeah oh
yeah I guess I just remember denji and
makima and power like I I kind of get
that because I um I I think this just
reflects my real life as well I'm just
awful with names I'm so bad I'm so bad
at me like so many I have so many people
have meeting up with like three or four
times yeah I feel like I'm too deep to
ask them for their name again okay but I
don't know it yeah I I'm like like this
isn't that bad no no I'm excited three
is like the magic number right and then
like after three I cannot actually I'm
like this is too much this is too much
so many times I've met a person or I've
met someone but it's like YouTubers
right because they have screen names and
I know they're screen names I don't know
their real name yeah I I I have this I'm
gonna call myself out on this but like
every time I meet someone you and maybe
like I exchange lines with them right
yeah
um you know how you can like change the
names to whatever on your content that's
all right uh I do this thing where just
so I don't forget who they are I put
their name and then in brackets I put in
where I met them as their contact name
so I'd be like if I met a guy called
like Jacob uh in Osaka right and it was
like the first time in my barely talked
to him but we exchanged lines in my line
his contact would be Jason and then in
Brackets guy I met in Osaka that seems
so inevision no because it helps me to
remember this is like Memento like
you're chasing the plot to find out no
but then but then because I've had so
many moments where if it was just the
name I and you know maybe we don't
message for a while right and then I
suddenly get a message from Jason like a
couple of months later and I'll be like
who the [__] this guy again I I play
this game every time I have a family
reunion I played this game at my recent
wedding yeah in Thailand
um when I'd hopefully no one's none of
my family's watching this right now but
um I'd be talking to one of my aunts or
one of my cousins or something I haven't
met them in a while and I'd be like
it's even harder because they have Thai
names as well right so my brain is
trained obviously to English names yeah
to Western names because that's the
environment I grew up in
um so I know that I only have a certain
amount of cousins and I've met all of my
cousins and I remember all of the name
of my cousins but sometimes I'm like are
you this name oh are you that name and
I'm like
and and like I I love I love all of my
family and like we have a great time
every time we meet them but this time
especially was like an especially
extended period since I've met a lot of
my extended family
um and some some of my cousins I
actually used to be really close to and
it's because it's just been so long I
remember being at the wedding and uh a
few times like I was like yeah do you
remember do you remember where we when
we did this when we were kids and I was
like [__] that was a good memory and in
my mind I was like [__] what was his
name again is it is it is it this P or
is it that P I was just like I just like
do you remember Paul and it's like uh my
name's Pete yeah
it's like oh yes of course I knew that
yeah so I still got to like try and
figure out what I know there's a
probable life hack to be like how do you
ask for someone's name without knowing
you're asking for someone I think it's
impossible I think yeah uh you just have
to bite the bullet and if you think it's
you're gonna get caught out you just got
to be like what's your name yeah yeah
it's basically if it's just the two of
you then it's impossible but if there's
like a third person there then you can
just be like please say his name I had
uh I had like dinner with this guy he
was a YouTuber and he was talking about
how he met another YouTuber who doesn't
say their name but he also doesn't say
his name publicly and so he's saying
about how he couldn't remember the guy's
name that he told him one time and I was
like Ah that's so funny meanwhile I was
thinking [__] I can't remember your name
and I thought in my head I'm like I
should just ask now this is the perfect
opportunity yeah I didn't and I
regretted it so much because I still
don't know their name to this day I
still don't and I've hung out with them
three times
yeah it's like but I know their YouTube
name right yeah and I'm like and on
everything I have him on he it his real
name is not on it right yeah and I'm
like [__] I got it I gotta figure out at
that point I'm just like I'm sorry to
sound like an [__] but yeah tell me
what your name is again obviously it
would be totally fine if I just say it
yeah if I just say I'm a [__] idiot
yeah I forgot your name No One's Gonna
Give a [__] no but also it's like I
don't know in your head for some reason
you think it's gonna always gonna be
worse than it is like you kick it down
the road and hope they say it it's like
yeah it's like so bad for me that
sometimes I ask for someone's name and
as like they say it I like oh that's
cool and I'll immediately forget it and
you just you immediately just forget it
they literally said that name like five
micro seconds ago and you're like I've
already forgotten that yeah I wish I
wish I was [__] as good with names I was
with faces like I feel like I'm so good
with faces like I remember I retain
faces really well but not names yeah I
think that's very common though yeah I
mean yeah I feel because like I I'm so
bad with names but like when I look I
would look at a face of like a photo
like in real life and I'd be like I've
definitely met you before yeah I just
forgot what your name was and what you
do
but I know we've met
somewhere I recognize that face from
somewhere whenever I think I know
someone's face at like a like a fan meet
up like if they've come a few times over
however long yeah I'll always go for it
I'm like I met you before yeah yeah and
90 of the time they're like nope
I'm like I don't think so either no no
then then you can use that to be like
okay because you the one time you do
remember they're like yeah yo yeah so
now I'm gonna break everyone's dreams
here I said to our dude no I say you see
if I I if I've I've been in situations
like that before with fans and not like
how I [__] kind of get myself out of it
would be like oh because you look like
someone I've met before yeah no because
I feel like I I just got on the full
limb dick on table I'm like I've made
before yeah and then like no no no no
that's a problem you don't you don't you
don't come in as a question because the
payoff is so good like that like I feel
like what because the few times I've
been right I'm not just saying this to
everyone everyone's gonna be like
everyone's gonna start trolling me the
few times I did get it right they would
they would look so genuinely happy that
I was like yeah
yeah but like think about like the rate
that's like you know being like uh this
next Pokemon move gonna be critical hit
well it's like it's like well it was the
success rate as time went on and
obviously the audience grew yeah I got
worse at it of course for the first few
years I was I was so good at this names
not names I returned faces so well and I
remember who I had met for sure
sometimes people are like do you
remember me and I was like no they're
like oh I cosplayed this person I'm like
well help me out here you were
cosplaying how am I supposed to remember
you yeah or like the worst is uh
sometimes people come up to you I think
I've said this before because they'll be
like do you remember me we I I tweeted
at you I'm like what no yeah my Twitter
name is this and I have this anime
character is my profile picture I'm like
how how would I how would I put that
together
how like I've never seen you I haven't
seen your face I haven't seen your name
and now you come to me in person with a
name and you think I can connect the two
how oh yes Jason uh anime fan247 with
nagator as a profile picture I knew that
yeah obviously yeah you look like uh
yeah
I I remember the best like one of one of
the best saves I've ever done in my life
sure regarding this was uh this this is
all also back in University and I I was
I was at a party
and uh I got along I got along really
well with this guy
um and I was like yeah let's let's hook
up that's like let's like hang out again
uh I'd asked us I'd ask for his name
multiple times in this party you know
this was like this was like three or
four times
um and he goes sure just uh this is this
is like college you know this college
for me so everyone's still using
Facebook he was like sure just add me on
Facebook
single sweat stops dropping and I'm like
no you just be like what's the second
yeah yeah yeah I was like
so how do you how how do you spell your
name again and he goes uh Dave
I'm like oh [__] he knows he definitely
knows I'm like I just had this moment
and we were just like no no your second
name
okay I I still think back to that moment
you know sometimes you get a get like a
memory and I think back to that moment
all the time are you Dave yeah what's
your second name Come On Come On Dave no
no no no
oh my God you're right the worst one I
had was
um like years ago I I did some work for
like this Japanese gaming company right
and I met like a bunch of their team
right there's like three or four of them
all together right and you know
obviously a lot of like new faces and
stuff and then the head guy I was in
contact with was like okay uh you know
we'll keep working together I'll make a
line group with uh all of us all of them
that you met and I'm like okay sweet you
know because I wasn't gonna go home and
remember these names I'm just straight
yeah but it was so bad because it was me
and these four other Japanese people
three of them have the exact same
surname what is it like yeah it was like
shuttle and I'm just like which one was
which which subtle are you because it's
just this suppose for all of them and
I'm like
you got to help me out here bro like at
least put your picture or like you know
what position you're in like in the
company or something I'm like which
which cycle am I supposed to contact
it's [__] horrible